украина
да да нужно говорить по-русски стив ну
потому что на самом деле у нас
и если можно степи скажи пару слов и
представлю остальных у нас встреча в том
числе и же ежемесячно происходит разные
встречи скира с людьми которые учить
разные языки то есть если вы индикаторы
учу врезка если есть люди которые
вычетом испанские есть люди которые учат
японские так далее и мы решили что
хорошо поделать и вот такую встречу для
русскоязычных хотя бы 1 месяц потому что
есть много людей которые пользуются
маленьком русскоязычные украиноязычные
но если мага вещей которые стоило бы
больше раскрыть и сегодня вот у нас
такая первой встрече мы подумали что
неплохо бы встретиться наверное с теми
людьми которые преподают по методу
стелла и ведомости вы тоже будет
интересно потому что получается что уже
другие люди преподают так как стив сам
занимается и учит язык и я представлю
оксана преподаватель
школе икигай напомню собственно наши
школы онлайн она учит по методу стива и
оксана является преподавателем
английского и французского
вот потом я думаю на самосе расскажут
как нам еще должна присоединиться саша
стив я думаю вы помните сашу
вы бы встречались еще когда поливки или
она должны к нам присоединится наверно
опаздывает и кристина кристина является
новичков я буквально рассказал мы
буквально познакомились неделю назад
или я рассказал о системе стива у
кристины довольно интересный опыт потому
что кристина преподает по обычной школе
от киеве и соответственно ей очень
довольно интересны разные методики у нее
есть опыт работы с детьми и со взрослыми
я думаю у нее будет много вопросов вот в
остальном как вы хотите построить беседу
стив вы хотите начать либо начнем сразу
с оксаной кристина
меня имеет мы можем тоже говорить
по-английский французский разбавляет
украинскую мову ну хорошо давайте просто
может быть оксана с тебя начнем скажешь
пару слов о себе может есть вопрос какой
то в силу
потом дальше уже пройдет я переводчик по
образованию я учил английский и
[музыка]
также вы можете общаться с другими
советскими это очень интересно я
подумываю о том чтобы выучить еще
какие-нибудь языке но до момента когда я
познакомилась с концепция estima я не
думал что это два это уже теперь мне
интересно
выучить еще какие-нибудь поскольку
французские то романские языки
собой логично испанские и они очень
близки и очень сложны и в принципе если
я письменно читают а смысл расширить
свои знания
попробовать еще раз
у меня такой вопрос как вы считаете стив
чего лучше начать лучше начать начать
испанский конечно знаю английский язык
то значит я например когда я начинаю
начала изучать русский язык до меня
проблема номер один это киришский
но если вы уже знает английский но
конечно не является проблема этой
ситуации 50 процентов ну да лески и
испанский
то же самое более или менее поэтому нет
проблема писание проблем нет проблем в
принципе
половина спасовали запас знаете поэтому
очень просто конечно произношению и
грамматике но есть некий элемент который
я сейчас когда я начинаю это это не был
ситуация сейчас я начинаю с мини store
гликин сказке всегда по-арабски поттер
сельские потерять и по-гречески
всегда не с грамматики не система
семенец и
объяснение я начинаю с содержанием более
или менее интересно не очень интересно
но там есть самой само использование
даты самой важно без благом мы не можем
говорить и много много повторений каждой
сказке есть пять повторений
сказки из другой точки зрения и
предложения и и питание и потом я слушаю
я один и каждое утро когда я приготовлю
завтрак я кушаю и концу я буду слушать
23 сказки и после я уже имею чувства я
имею да это язык как это работает ну
иногда могу на случай испанского языка
есть проблема когда я ищу что то я и
использую контекст это очень хороший там
есть если я например из кучи вас куча
куча я могу искать это эту форму глагола
и
уже времени я оближу вес надо надо
верить систем до продолжаться и слушать
и первые 3 месяцев месяца я только
занимаю министра есть это случае
арабский или греческий языки да есть
процесс писания из проблем нет много
запасы языке если вы знаете английский
вы можете использовать что угодно
поэтому не надо сказать и не сложно это
это это не не это неправда потому что
даже если вы знаете португальский
русский язык надо привыкнуть много-много
слышать это и даже арабские когда я для
меня это это и не только я ничего не
не не понял и надо привыкнуть описание
арабские начну с места после больше
кристина может быть перед у меня вопрос
очень много потому что я прослушала
только один вебинар кости вводный
вебинар я работаю правда действительно
работу в государственной школе работы с
детьми разного возраста и у меня есть
но я являюсь репетитором не только
легитимнее взрослая и это мне очень
интересно как взрослого человека но я у
меня были вопросы в течении вебинара
кости и отвечал на эти вопросы мои
которые возникали в голове потому что я
сталкиваюсь с тем что когда взрослый
человек хочет обучиться языку самое
тяжелое для ну я вот смотрю его тяжело
мотивировать вот он не хочет делать
задания он не хочет ему трудно начать
разговаривать ему но все сложно вот
буквально каждая ступенька является хотя
вроде бы человек хочет очень хочет
научиться говорить и вас кости на
выражения в течении вебинара что
мотивация не является чем-то хорошим в
данном случае мы часто теряем был
интерес мне вот понравилось но сейчас
вроде как вопросов много но
сформулировать пока это очень сложно мне
интересно послушать как
ну как это происходит я прочитала я знаю
что идет 7 недель до на слушание и
чтение правильно я понимаю я запомнила
правильно сервер день вкушение и чистая
и просто и повторение пассивное
абсолютно восприятие информации
сложно мне пока представить семьи этих
волшебных недель человек вот выстрелит
потому что я склонна к методике
школе опять же что нужно развивать
четыре вида деятельности одновременно
можно отливать чтение нужно развивать
тушение нужно говорение разбивать и
письмо
плюс еще было бы неплохо 5 и пункта как
лексика своих детей ну я их своими
называют то и кучу
под свои детей я развиваю вот так потому
что они должны у меня успеть за 45 минут
урока успеть сделать четыре вида
деятельности тогда я считаю ну или хотя
бы три тогда я считаю что урок на прошел
успешно
поэтому мне очень интересно каким
образом человек читающий только и
слушающие извините у меня свет очень
падает и меня я вижу что засвеченное
солнце каким образом человек вот только
слушая и читая
грамма вот этого я пока далека я не знаю
как это происходит и там возможно только
когда ты сам попробуешь может сахно не
знаю я училась этому но конечно все
зависит от ситуации
я нет у меня нет я могу через интернет и
я сделал и надо сказать когда я скажу я
говорю что я только случаю китаю
но например когда я изучал я сказал мой
канал я буду говорить я
деле я говорил чтобы сформировать и
когда я начинал я тоже сказать для меня
взрослые люди они я не думаю что они не
имеют мотивации они очень быстро теряет
мотивации потому что они они хотят
говорить я хочу говорить по-испански и
как данные были в мексике я не говори я
хочу говорить
но начинает изучать и очень быстро
теряет мотивации и
и нет чувство достижения на нее нет
чувства успехов и мы мы нуждаемся
чувство успеха морск
хочет успех если будет успех это
надевать и
чтобы говорить правильно не говоря
по-русски который это правильно это
сложно и и особенности
первые начали когда мы начинаем новый
язык говорить говорить правильно
исправленном произношение очень очень
сложно я думаю понимать они постепенно в
виде как не понимаем мочите
раньше это меня мне кажется легко
достигнуть это чувство поэтому и есть
много
способ читать и слышать например на
случай я всегда использую арабский
polski я могу видеть только предложение
и там я могу голос тонко и нет так всю
спину бонус нарратора могу служить я
могу попробовать
имитировать интонация и произношения
только 1 предложение
и это это я еду для меня это это способ
говорить потому что я должен имитировать
я читаю я могу сосредоточиться на
может быть словами запас может быть
конструкция фразы грамматики и потом я
слушаю цельные сказки
не больше всего когда я не бегаю я
приготовлю завтрак и потом я опять читаю
и для меня это интересно потому что
и для меня это видно что я понимаю
больше если я использую ли я вижу что
мои лекции который в начале были только
синий добру и сейчас больше
или или белый всё это во мне да да дают
ощущение что у меня есть прогресс я могу
тоже смотрите моей статистике и
это и у меня нет фрустрации но если я
хочу говорить в первые начали
будет ось очень сложно и если будет
например как и в каждый каждый
начинающий
много теста про язык и конечно я не могу
я будет на самой лучи ситуации и здесь
будет или 35 к понимание
если если у меня будет хороший уровень
та нема
и соответствующая слова не за память о
том и мучить уровень
умение говорить будет нелегко но были
ногти ногти
но все-таки рад что я дьявол например
читать по-арабски по системе не не очень
просто потому что не только это для меня
новые но это не как по-русски или
по-испански и болен гони 1 а за 1 это
буква и коз это звук парочки это не так
поэтому очень сложно но я читал лютером
за преподавателей и я читать и она мне
сказали нет это не так это не надо я
например иногда если понимали что я че
то не понял я понял я не я читал у меня
не надо меня
но и да вот это для преподавателей
это хорошо это вид я работаю но я думаю
для изучающие не стоит спросить если я
помню но я немножко понял и два месяца
потом я буду больше понимать понимать
для меня это не так как неделя так что
люди будет период терять мотивации
потому что мотивации есть он или она
хочет говорить по-испански или по-русски
и по-английски но не надо не надо и там
содержит уровень чувство достижения
успеха и конечно искать или помогать им
не искать содержание который для них
интересно может быть кухня может быть
музыка может и строго то да се
сила присоединилась саша саша раз
которая стив и знакомые может быть саше
тогда тоже этой скажешь пару слов о себе
задачу опустил
до я
меня зовут александра встречались в
прошлом году мне
я ножка помогаю кости развивать проекты
кидай и некоторых процессах включена в
этой школе и я уже стыдясь типа тьютором
для людей которые изучают английский
язык при помощи linq рынке за не читают
читают и слушают активно пользуюсь
системой библиотекой а я им помогаю
разговорной практики или с вопросами
которые у них есть возникают по ходу и
очень классные vision результаты
потому что вижу что очень многие люди
действительно и мне надоедают учить язык
потому что они используются те материалы
которые они сами находят которые
действительно интересные и
это очень дорого никогда не пенаты не
надоедает как может надоесть учебник
какое-нибудь упражнение ну и короче или
же очень-очень хорошие результаты людей
нет очень но и опять же скажу что может
быть это не для всех и наверное есть
люди которым действительно хочется иметь
преподавателя которые им рассказывал что
им ся делать вот некоторые люди такие но
они рискуют может быть но мне нравится
то что прайс то что если ради людей
которые я вижу как они растут которые
пользуются программы то есть система
ride разработан стив от очень здорово а
я за последний год языки новые
я я питаюсь я-я-я потому что я но я
изучал французский испанский
португальский румынский это один русский
и я знаю китайский и японский мог .
корейский поэтому я еще я хочу знать
больше о называемого ближний восток
ближние поэтому но я я изучал греческий
потому что я был с 32 года больше всего
арабский это сложно я могу я у меня есть
сотрудник сотрудник герани она делает
вещи про для нас очень дорого и
между прочим в том числе история ирана
есть и после каждый эпизод
эпизод то же самое как мы называем
circling on
она что-то скажет потом сбросить и потом
отличает и когда я слушаю
эпизод я понимаю и потом я слушаю и
потом я понимаю побольше поэтому поэтому
я слушаю подкаст из озера и у меня есть
сотрудника нет я не могу сказать что я
хорошо говорю по-тайски арабский говорю
но я много сейчас вы знал это регионы и
и не только читаю и слушаю по-арабски
эпические но читаю по-английски потому
что это интересно ли они например
persia российские влияния я не знаю
большое влияние поэтому я это занимаю и
это интересно я не я не заботится о
уровень пролез хотя может быть я буду
делать видео по
арабский несколько лекарств
это я занимаю я тоже все зависит от
ситуации ситуации когда я изучать
китайский у меня три часа 11 до 11 это
самая вас есть возможность говорить
казеин три часа
когда я понял я говорю первым наталья
кого дельце кого угодно но я сейчас у
меня есть другой даже когда я был балкон
и я изучал к
ейске это растение я пони и я бегом
гонга и тоже 50 лет ума назад никто
никого не говори по сейчас не только
после 3 часа урок я слышу то же самое
биополе
поэтому питание и слушание
очень сильный способ изучения который
это может быть фундаментальный у вас
есть преподаватель можете говорить с
языка
те которые и пока меня случае сосчитать
это самое важная вещь и потом есть и
трасс и говорит скутера или я да но
слышат они и мы попробуем глинки
делать так что решение и тебя не стар .
эффективно ли фиг тебе
стив если нужно я папа тебя вопрос это
задам
можно попросить вас рассказать про роль
преподавателя будущего кольцу роль
преподавателя меняется берегу соли от
классической стены от классических
объяснений и особенно в системе link
дэн тюрон тьютора роль преподавателя
сильными изменилась и в общем-то оксана
знает вот саша знает кристина надеюсь и
будет интересно это узнать они уже
пытаются преподавать людям используя
систему ленту и я полагаю роль совсем
другая не такая как
других курсах либо когда они сами
преподают вот мне интересно я если я
вижу для меня это сложно который имел я
самый важный самый большой влияние на
меня это не был профессор которые знали
это сочи французского языка который
первый не потому что это профессор знал
французский другие потому что он меня
стимулируя он делает так то французский
язык стал интересно потому что этого
французский язык что робин не интересна
не только для меня не интересно но он
делать так что это стало это и потом я
изучал французский и я никогда думал что
я могу как человек
[музыка]
начинать говорить свободно на другой
другом языке то есть французский и потом
у меня был сам обернусь и
и когда и возможность когда я работал
правительства в пиратский изучать
китайский
я ничего не боялся конечно могу могу
поэтому влияние поэтому при по дороге на
меня первое первое это это надо надо 7
панзер симпатизировать конечно но надо
посрать
стимулировать мод имеет мотивировать это
самое важно и я думаю традиционный
скажем решение всегда бил что источник
знания
какой-либо язык это преподавать знает я
не знаю из преподавать его меня ой дают
гильзы
потому что она он или она знает и это
знание она у меня это так это не так
потому что знания если я хочу искать
русский глагол миллион возможность
искать поэтому знания так знания самая
важная вещь это мотивировать говорить
всем позиции мотивировать и искать
содержание песни страницей которые для
них уровень и совпадает их уровень и их
интерес и когда например когда я работал
с лютером через интернет есть хороший не
хороший случай женщины лучше чем более
гибкий если я ск и я говорю я ник
сегодня мы будем изучать думаю я не хочу
но мы будем это потому что есть такая
программа будем делать да и потом потом
цвета и даже не хочу гибкий и
и и отвечает на интерес новый говорить
говорить по
язык который изучаем и
и искать способ когда мы говорим хороший
титр делая так что я дня не должен
думать о чем будем говорить она
обязательно ищет вещи который для меня
интересна и который я могу я могу
говорить и мы говорим и очень я без
фильтрации и потом через
она меня просирает лист до
список список разве который меня проблем
и я изучаю и она тоже
это записывает это это у меня есть до 61
год каждый урок который я слышу я голос
и она читает да надо повторить
много раз преподаватель на мой взгяд где
находится интересный сможет я искать от
совпадающие много работа но и для меня
если знает где находится эти вещи это
много много помогает
если могу потом я слышал что-то про
ситуация и потом я могу об этом говорить
со пьютера по-арабски это это очень
хорошо поэтому
станет гид и
[музыка]
вдруг и будет знания языка это
это очевидно не без знания языка
невозможно но это не
не хватит это тебе aprica
спасибо стив вопросы у меня
если есть например когда будет я думаю
что есть детали конечно помогать искать
содержание если да да да и скачи что для
этого человека интересно и помогать его
это искать а если если слишком сложно
это не моделировать если слишком легко
это тоже не надо искать помогать есть
как никогда а я тут я попробую не
слишком много я могу использовать
вы знаете правильный не правильно
ответить использовать правильный речь и
потом на мои моем случае я она будет
посягать
потом я поливаем
мы скажем из тех не надо
интересный меч
ну когда вы исправите не надо это
зависит от из люди которые
но будет ученики которые я думаю что я
не знаю но ведь взрослые люди для меня
это более возможно но если userinfo
задать вопрос пару слов по поводу
преподавания 11 группе
маленький нет понятия преподавания для
группы только 11 почему нельзя но я
думаю до 4 ночи были
но я думаю о тебе и большинство людей
предпочитают 11 сам я не хочу слышать
людей которые говорят или
который говорят я не могу понимать если
там будет акцент что я я я я предпочитаю
нынче урок неделе 23 1 недели 11 и и это
лучше чем мэра каждый день 3:04 не хочу
я понимаем
но хорошо у кого-то еще есть вопросы
если нет через почти я нахожусь в ялте
красота
вроде на гоголя
такая ситуация вас ходите и каждый день
10 более
небольшой большое спасибо спасибо до
свидания
bakida кубачи de poche
[музыка]